good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson's and happy friday
in retrospect joe biden's first term
policy agenda
seems very optimistic almost comically
optimistic shortly before his
inauguration biden announced something
he called the build back better agenda
of course we mocked it at the time but
looking back it was in some ways a
hopeful document
america must have been a very rich
country back then and by back then we
mean last year
there weren't a lot of essentials in
biden's agenda the first three things
that any normal nation needs and thinks
about obsessively are food water and
energy that's the standard in china for
example every government policy foreign
and domestic is designed above all to
secure adequate reserves of food water
and energy and that makes sense
the buildback better agenda was the
opposite of that
it did not suggest any concern at all
about whether americans might have
enough to eat or could afford enough
heating fuel to keep from freezing to
death over the winter
biden's agenda was focused on the kind
of added extras you get to and you fixed
everything else and then still have
trillions left over buildback better
promised us something called
environmental equity whatever that is it
demanded amnesty for millions of illegal
aliens because at the time the american
economy seemed robust enough to share
with the entire world universal health
care for honduras biden called for free
solar panels for everybody and
taxpayer-funded pre-k for all american
parents and so on and on
buildback better was the neoliberal
version of flying cars it was a dreamy
christmas list of luxuries that for a
moment in time seemed almost within
reach
a lot has changed nobody's talking about
flying cars anymore here's joe biden
from yesterday
with regard to food shortage yes we did
we
talk about food shortages
and uh and it's going to be real
the price of these sanctions is not just
imposed upon russia it's imposed upon an
awful lot of countries as well including
european countries and our country as
well
and because both
russia and ukraine
have been the bread basket of europe in
terms of wheat for example just give one
example
food shortages biden said quote they're
going to be real once again in case you
missed it to repeat
food shortages not in sudan in
cincinnati in reno in spokane and
norfolk and of course in our big cities
too we're not a single person who is
born here has any idea what a food
shortage is
our problem has always been having too
much food now we won't have enough we
know that because the president united
states just told us that on camera
so what is this going to mean how do
food shortages affect a country
well if you're interested go online and
read about it all of recorded history
will answer your question a food
shortage is not like deciding to skip
dessert
it's not a diet it's not voluntary a
food shortage is different it's scary
food shortages topple governments they
turn moderates into revolutionaries a
food shortage is a big deal you don't
want one
but now we're getting one just a little
over a year into joe biden's presidency
think forward if the traditional
calendar holds we've got
1032 days left of the joe biden
administration
and you wonder what things will look
like by then we're already speeding
toward dystopia not the white house
seems aware of it or to care in any way
here's treasury secretary janet yellen
from this morning for example letting
you know it's time to stop whining about
gas prices because actually they're not
very high
how high do you think oil prices can get
at the pump
uh listen i
there's a lot of uncertainty about it
they're not as high in real terms as
they were
earlier earlier in this century
and um
they you know it's conceivable that they
could move higher
yeah it's not a big deal settle down and
there's a reason for it as joe biden
explained you're paying more for gas
because we have slapped sanctions on
russia and sanctioning russia is the
right thing to do so shut up and feel
virtuous as you slowly go broke
now for some people particularly those
who don't drive cars this might seem
like an adequate answer but others in
good faith may ask okay
i'm not against sanctions in theory
but since they're clearly not hurting
putin and they clearly are now hurting
my family what is the point of sanctions
is there a point let me know make me
feel better
and the answer is yes america there's a
point to sanctions sanctions are
designed to prevent russia from invading
ukraine
we know that because not so long ago
tony blinken the secretary of state told
cnn that quote the purpose of the
sanctions in the first instance is to
try to deter russia from going to war
and then jen saki the president's
publicist backed him up quote our
intention is to have a deterrent effect
with sanctions
kamala harris agreed
the difference she said the deterrent
effect of these sanctions is still a
meaningful one
so sanctions were
except they didn't actually work putin
invaded ukraine anyway the sanctions
failed
so what's the response admit they fail
try something new no
joe biden is pretending that the
administration never claimed sanctions
would deter russia from invading ukraine
here's the new line
let's get something straight you
remember if you covered me from the very
beginning i did not say that in fact the
sanctions would deter him
sanctions never deter
you keep talking about that
sanctions never deter the maintenance of
sanctions
the maintenance of sanctions the
increasing the pain and the
demonstration why i ask for this nato
meeting today is to be sure that after a
month we will sustain what we're doing
not just next month the following month
but for the remainder this entire year
that's what will stop him
what does that even mean
sanctions never deter why do you keep
saying that he said well because you
kept saying that
your white house press secretary your
vice president your secretary of state
all said that verbatim
but they're not acknowledging that
hoping that our memories have been so
damaged by the iphone will be as
forgetful as joe biden himself now they
want us to believe that sanctioning
russia can force putin into withdrawing
from ukraine
is that true
can putin be sanctioned into retreat
well we certainly hope it's true
sincerely
but there's no evidence that it is true
there's not even really an expectation
that it's true even joe biden didn't
claim that was going to happen
so what is the point
we're not sure
that's a topic for another show but in
the meantime this country we know this
for sure is being badly hurt by those
sanctions as reuters recently reported
quote western sanctions on russia a
major exporter of potash ammonia urea
and other soil nutrients have disrupted
shipments of those key inputs around the
globe fertilizer is key to keeping corn
soy rice and wheat yields high growers
are scrambling to adjust
you following this
those ingredients are necessary to put
food on your table at a price you can
afford if you don't have those
ingredients what do you get
food shortages which are a direct result
of policy from the white house
a policy
whose intended effect is still not clear
what is the point of this if there's a
good point people will put up with it
why don't you tell us what that point is
fertilizer bills are expected to jump
around 15 just this year and they could
go higher some farmers say they're
already seeing fertilizer prices go much
higher than that watch
mike gunderson's family has been farming
wheat soybeans and corn on this land
since the 1950s he expects the weather
to throw him a curveball and farming but
not a war
all the stuff in ukraine there's so much
volatility in the market the u.s imports
10.3 billion dollars worth of fertilizer
for crops 1.3 billion of that comes from
russia which is now off the market the
minnesota association of wheat growers
says farmers lay down fertilizer at
least twice a year there's a lot of
fertilizers that are 4 and 5x more
expensive than they were
a year ago fertilizer has drastically
outpaced the rate of inflation russia's
ban on fertilizer is scheduled to last
until the end of the year and while
supply is already tight this year it's
the future many are worried about
so sanctions have thrown american
agriculture into profound turmoil and
will cause again as the president has
told us out loud food shortages which
are maybe the most destabilizing trend
you could ever have in a country not
just to the politics but to the social
fabric it's scary
but it's not just sanctions
there are a lot of reasons it's not just
the war in ukraine
in response to energy and food shortages
the bite administration is shutting down
domestic oil and gas production
that makes food more expensive it makes
everything else more expensive and as
the pressure on american farmers rises
and as food becomes scarcer and more
expensive in this country that same
administration is allowing the
government of china to buy up this
country's farmland
according to politico and this was two
years ago chinese investors owned nearly
200 000 acres of u.s ag land valued at
at least 2 billion
now they're doing this in part with the
help of subsidies paid for by u.s
taxpayers and chinese investors are
continuing to buy more every single year
again
food
water energy that's what you need for a
country the chinese understand that as
congressman dan newhouse put it quote
the current trend of the united states
is leading us toward the creation of a
chinese-owned agricultural land monopoly
in our country
the most productive farmland in the
world
now owned by what we used to call our
main global rival and i think we can now
say with the realignment in progress is
our main global enemy
owned by a country that seeks to
displace us and punish us
it's insane would the chinese government
permit american investors to buy its
country's farmland or water resources
that's not even a real question of
course not no sane country would do that
and no foreign entity should be allowed
to control america's critical natural
resources
so how long until the chinese start
scooping up the great lakes which are
our largest reservoirs of fresh water
food water energy don't laugh that's
where we're headed
and it could happen much sooner than
anyone seems to realize fishing
companies are paying such high costs
they're running out of business here's
another fox multimedia report watch
gas prices are jacking up the cost of
boat rentals and charters
leaving captains like cody kinney with
two choices cancel charters that are not
profitable or increase ticket prices the
increases are not just hitting the
tourism industry from our boats that go
out fishing to our trucks that deliver
the product everything that we use to
run our business
we see at least a 35 percent increase
nello cassarino runs galveston shrimp
company he says passing those prices
onto the consumer is not a reliable
option because the consumer at some
point will stop buying it it turns into
a
ripple effect where the plants have to
lay off employees
you know trucks stop moving
all part of our food supply now
imperiled through a remarkable
combination of negligence and terrible
decision-making not just by this
administration by previous
administrations but brought to the point
of crisis by joe biden and by the way
it's not just a question of what it
costs to fuel a commercial fishing fleet
the oceans themselves are being depleted
of fish entire species by the chinese
government you hear a lot about the
environment and saving the planet
by which they mean don't drive an suv
but the actual planet its actual
resources its oceans the most important
resource the planet has it's not about
climate it's about the oceans
and increasingly they're polluted and
bereft of fish
and china's doing that we're not and no
one's saying a word about it
so instead of addressing any of these
problems our leaders are responding in
the one way they know how they're
throwing more money at the problem and
in the process devaluing the us dollar
that we're going to desperately need to
stay solvent california governor gavin
newsom for example just announced he's
about to give his residents another free
credit card
so today we're announcing a nine billion
dollar tax refund to tens of millions of
californians four hundred dollars for
each registered vehicle that an
individual owns up to two vehicles that
direct relief will address the issue
that we all are struggling to address
and that's the issue of gas prices
so if the hands and the hair and the
teeth distracted you and you didn't
actually hear anything that governor
newsome said what he's saying is tax
prices are really high so we're going to
give you a tax refund whether or not you
pay taxes if it's welfare
and that's going to solve the problem
what he doesn't say is that california
has the highest gas prices in america
because it has the highest gas taxes in
america seven bucks a gallon in los
angeles seven bucks
he did that
but instead of fixing it he's making you
more dependent and this is a trend for
the second time in two years politicians
are sending out welfare checks to
compensate for economic crises that they
caused
so if you wanted to increase inflation
if you wanted to make the population
weak and dependent upon you
this is what you'd probably do
free bread next
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight